This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养坚韧的精神、强健的体魄以及建立心理韧性。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你终将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“2”加“percent”，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上均可收听。欢迎收听《Look Back at It》播客。从1979年开始，对我来说那是意义重大的一年。84年对我影响也很大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有哪个年份比这更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，各位，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位懂行的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须要这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，这份特定的检测报告是你篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。互联网侦探们动用了大量人力，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们在20岁时面临的人生重大改变与转型，以及它们意味着什么的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course,
对于我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的又一期节目，当然，我们要
break down the psychology of our 20s. All right. Breakups in our 20s, they suck. Okay, they are just awful. No other words to describe it. They leave just a huge, gaping whole in our lives and a ton of unanswered questions, especially when that relationship felt like endgame. You know, you go from planning a future with this person to it ending and
剖析20多岁时的心理。好了。20多岁时的分手，真的很糟糕。好吧，它们简直糟透了。找不到别的词来形容了。它们在我们的生活中留下了一个巨大的、空洞的缺口，以及一堆未解的问题，特别是当那段感情感觉像是命中注定的时候。你知道的，你从计划和这个人共度未来，到它戛然而止，
walking away and them not being in your life anymore. And even though you may know in your deepest heart of hearts that it was the right decision, it can still very much feel like you wasted the last four, six, eight years of your life and you have to start over. This big question comes up, well, how do I do that? How do I start over when this person was such a formative part of my 20s? More specifically, how do I make up for lost time? How do I still have all the experiences I didn't get to have whilst still feeling like I'm on schedule in my life? Well, there is a very unique phenomenon that happens after this kind of long-term breakup. that I have been noticing more and more.
分道扬镳，这个人不再出现在你的生活里。尽管你内心深处可能知道这是正确的决定，但你还是会觉得，自己仿佛浪费了过去四、六年、八年的生命，一切都得从头开始。这就带来了一个巨大的问题：好吧，我该怎么做？当这个人曾是你20岁时如此重要的组成部分时，我该如何重新开始？更具体地说，我如何弥补失去的时间？如何在感觉自己的人生依然按部就班的同时，还能拥有所有我未能拥有的经历？好吧，在经历这种长期恋爱关系的分手后，有一个非常独特的现象。我注意到这种现象越来越普遍。
And it's this kind of second puberty that is triggered by the end of a significant relationship that has spanned the majority of your 20s. And I want to really discuss exactly what takes place and this new term that I've come up to describe this called post-long-term relationship puberty. It is this weird chapter in our lives after relationship ends. in which people experience like insane character shifts and development and like rapid expansion and growth and exploration and all these amazing things whilst they're also trying to navigate heartache and it feels like they're almost like a teenager again there's this very similar pattern
这就是那种由一段持续了你20岁大部分时间的重大恋爱关系的结束所触发的“第二青春期”。我真的想探讨一下究竟发生了什么，以及我为描述这一现象而创造的一个新词——“长期恋爱后青春期”。这是我们生活中一段奇怪的章节，发生在恋爱关系结束之后。在这段时期里，人们会经历疯狂的性格转变与发展，就像快速膨胀、成长和探索一样，伴随着所有这些奇妙的事情，他们同时也在努力应对心碎，感觉自己几乎像个青少年一样。这种模式非常相似。
that these breakups tend to follow and i want to explain what that pattern is but also how we can best kind of confront the confusion that is left in the wake of a long-term relationship. How do we know when we can date again? How do you know if you made a mistake? How to make the most out of being single after a big period, a big chunk of your life of being monogamous. So there is a lot going on, but it can all be described by this term and I want to tell you what it means, explain it to you, answer all those questions.
这些分手往往遵循着这样的模式，我想解释一下这种模式是什么，以及我们如何才能最好地去面对长期恋爱关系结束后所遗留下的困惑。我们怎么知道什么时候可以再次开始约会？你怎么知道自己是不是犯了错误？在经历了一大段长期的、专一的生活之后，如何充分利用单身生活？所以有很多事情正在发生，但这一切都可以用这个词来概括，我想告诉你它意味着什么，向你解释，并回答所有这些问题。
And hopefully if you are going through this right now, this episode's as a little bit of a guide to navigating this kind of heartache we know is necessary, but maybe didn't expect, and just how to get the absolute most out of this next chapter of your life despite, you know, a lot of confusing feelings. So without further ado, let's discuss the psychology of post-long-term relationship puberty. So let me begin by describing exactly what this phrase means. So when people first hear me talk about post-long-term relationship, puberty, they are often kind of like, huh? Like, they're a little bit confused, but when I describe it to them, they will almost always immediately say to me, I know someone who's like that,
希望如果你现在正经历这一切，这期节目能成为一点小小的指南，指引你如何去应对我们知道不可避免、却又始料未及的心碎，以及在面对许多令人困惑的感受时，如何充分利用你人生的下一个章节。废话不多说，让我们来探讨一下“长期恋爱后青春期”的心理学。那么，让我先来描述一下这个短语的确切含义。因此，当人们第一次听到我谈论“长期恋爱后青春期”时，他们通常会感到一头雾水，像是在说：哈？他们会觉得有点困惑，但当我向他们描述时，他们几乎总是会立刻对我说：“我认识一个人就是这样的，
or they will start describing someone in their own life who fits the exact bill, because although no one really has a name for this phenomena yet, it is still so unbelievably common. I'm surprised no one has been able to label it. So this term, describe someone who was in a serious relationship for most of their early and mid-20s, who suddenly finds himself single at 27, 28, 29, on the cusp of 30. And having realized that they've sunk all this time into a person who wasn't the one, as a result, they feel like they have to make up for those lost opportunities, specifically the lost experiences of being single in their 20s. and they kind of go through almost a second emotional puberty of sorts.
或者他们会开始描述自己生活中的某个人，完全符合这种特征，因为尽管还没有人真正为这种现象命名，但它依然是如此不可思议地普遍。我很惊讶竟然没有人能给它贴上标签。所以这个词，用来描述那些在20岁出头和中旬的大部分时间里都处于一段严肃恋爱关系中，却突然发现自己在27岁、28岁、29岁、即将迈入30岁时恢复单身的人。由于意识到自己把所有这些时间都倾注在一个并不是对的人身上，结果，他们觉得自己必须弥补那些失去的机会，尤其是20多岁时作为单身人士所失去的经历。他们几乎经历了一种类似于第二次情感青春期的过程。
They suddenly start going out again after years of wanting to stay in. They start dating like they're 17. They feel giddy over first kisses. They feel confused and exhilarated. They're taking big risks. They're traveling. They're fighting with their parents. They're making major life changes.
在渴望宅家的多年之后，他们突然又开始出门社交了。他们像17岁时一样开始约会。他们为初吻感到眩晕。他们感到困惑又兴奋。他们正在冒着巨大的风险。他们去旅行。他们和父母吵架。他们正在做出重大的人生改变。
They're having sex with new people, discovering a whole new group of single friends. They're having this like insane mental and physical glower. almost because they spent all this time with someone else. They found themselves really defined by that relationship. And now that they're finally experiencing being single and truly independent in their 20s, it's like they're awake again. It's like they're alive. They are going through a major psychological growth spurt that they missed by partnering up with someone,
他们和新的人发生性关系，发现了一整群全新的单身朋友。他们正在经历这种疯狂的精神和身体上的蜕变。几乎是因为他们把所有时间都花在了另一个人身上。他们发现自己真正被那段感情所定义。现在，他们终于体验到了20多岁时的单身生活和真正的独立，感觉自己仿佛重新苏醒了。感觉自己活过来了。他们正在经历一个重大的心理成长爆发期，而这个爆发期是他们因为太早与某人建立伴侣关系而错过的。
specifically with the wrong person too soon. And it is wildly fun, but at the same time, it also creates a simple, panic and confusion for them because they were on track for hitting all these key milestones that society expects of them and now they won't be doing that. So there's this equal feeling of like, wait, I feel free, I feel great, but am I also falling behind? And at the same time, they're seeing all their friends who, you know, are settling down now after waiting a little bit longer. And it's kind of like the roles have reversed. Like they went from being the one who was serious and committed to being the single friend, but by the time they're back in their single
特别是太早和错误的人在一起。这极其有趣，但与此同时，这也为他们带来了单纯的恐慌和困惑，因为他们原本正朝着实现社会对他们期望的所有关键里程碑的轨道前进，而现在他们不会去做了。因此，有一种矛盾的心情：等等，我觉得自由了，我感觉很好，但我是不是也落后了？与此同时，他们看到所有那些稍微多等了一会儿、现在正安定下来的朋友们。这就好像角色对调了。就像他们从那个严肃、承诺的人，变成了单身的朋友，但当他们回到单身时代时，
error, all their friends have moved on. So much like puberty, where every day is very unique, and there's a lot of a big roller coaster of emotions and highs and lows, you're really in a period of rediscovering yourself. I also like to use the term puberty because, you know, you might not be experiencing the same physical and biological changes, but there are significant growing pains mentally as you're trying to adjust who you were before with who you are now. And a lot of that maturing is taking place through experimentation. Someone kind of described this phenomena to me like you've missed your exit on the highway by staying in this relationship for too long. And once you've realized that you've missed your exit and you leave the relationship, you find yourself having to
所有的朋友都已经翻篇了。就像青春期一样，每一天都是如此独特，情绪像坐过山车一样大起大落，充满了高潮与低谷，你实际上正处于重新发现自我的时期。我也喜欢用“青春期”这个词，因为，你知道，你可能没有经历相同的身体和生物学变化，但当你试图将过去的自己与现在的自己进行调和时，精神上会有明显的成长痛。而许多成熟的过程都是通过实验发生的。有人曾向我这样描述这种现象：你在这段感情中停留了太久，以至于在高速公路上错过了你的出口。一旦你意识到自己错过了出口并结束了这段关系，你就会发现自己不得不
drive all the way back to where you should have originally turned off to get back on track. You have to travel all the way back to the time and the age that you were when you first met that person and relive the way your life would have gone if you hadn't been with them to feel like you're really ready to enter the next chapter of your life. And in the last two years, I have seen countless friends and acquaintances go through this, go through this exact thing. And it always follows the exact same pattern. They met their person between 17 and 20, arguably when they were very, very young.
一路开车返回你最初应该拐弯的地方，以便回到正轨。你必须一路倒回你最初遇到那个人时的那个时间和年龄，重温如果你没有和他们在一起，你的人生会怎样，这样你才会觉得自己真正准备好进入人生的下一章。在过去的两年里，我看到无数的朋友和熟人经历这一切，经历这完全相同的事情。而且它总是遵循着完全相同的模式。他们在17岁到20岁之间遇到了那个对的人，可以说是在他们非常、非常年轻的时候。
They met them during a very formative period for establishing their own identity. The relationship was a meaningful one, right? It was a good enough relationship. This person was really nice. They were fine. And a lot of their experiences became tied to this person and therefore the partnership. So they traveled with their partner. They moved in together.
他们在一个对建立自我认同至关重要的时期遇到了对方。这段感情是有意义的，对吧？这是一段还不错的关系。这个人真的很不错。他们很好。他们的许多经历都与这个人联系在一起，因此也与这种伙伴关系联系在一起。所以他们和伴侣一起旅行。他们同居了。
They felt safe. but they didn't feel challenged. They didn't feel like their needs were fully met. And around their late 20s, they suddenly realized, like, this person isn't for me. And I cannot waste any more of my youth on them. I need to release both of us from this relationship, the good, not great, safe but not evolving relationship. And they break up with them.
他们感到安全。但他们没有感到被挑战。他们并不觉得自己被完全满足。到了快30岁的时候，他们突然意识到：这个人不适合我。我不能再把我的青春浪费在他们身上了。我需要把我们俩从这段关系中解放出来，这段美好但非绝佳、安全但却停滞不前的关系。他们和对方分手了。
And it feels like a really, really good decision. And then the cycle begins, the cycle of just exploring and exploding and doing, wild stuff that you didn't feel like you had the opportunity to do. So why does this happen? Why is this such a pattern that, you know, someone like me or other people have been able to come up with terms and words for it? So I have this major theory that a large majority of couples who have been together for a while and seemingly break up in the few years before 30, they do so because as you're approaching such a big milestone, it causes us to naturally sit. back and reflect. 30 is a new decade. It definitely feels like the beginning of a bigger, larger,
这感觉是一个非常、非常好的决定。然后循环开始了，探索、爆发的循环，做着那些你觉得自己之前没有机会做的疯狂的事情。那么，为什么会这样？为什么这会成为一种模式，让像我或其他一些人能够为它创造术语和词汇？我有一个重大的理论：很大一部分情侣在一起一段时间后，似乎在30岁前的几年里分手，他们之所以这样做，是因为当你接近这样一个重大的里程碑时，它会促使我们自然地坐下来。退后一步进行反思。30岁是一个新的十年。这绝对感觉像是一个更大、更广阔、
more mature, more adult chapter. Even though, you know, nothing really changes between 29 years and 12 months and 30 years and one month, but naturally, like, it feels significant. And so questions like, is this relationship right for me? Am I happy? Could I marry this person? Could I co-parent with this person? Is this what I'm? I imagine for myself, all these questions start to come up. So in psychology, this experience has a name. It's called a temporal landmark. So temporal landmarks are moments and time, like New Year's, birthdays, anniversaries, that really stand out from the flow of everyday life. And they act like mental, I don't know, mental chapter breaks. They make you really pause and reflect because, because of their significance, there's a very big sense of before. and after. And so things like turning 30, things like graduating, things like a five-year
更成熟、更成年的篇章的开始。尽管，你知道，在29岁零12个月和30岁零1个月之间并没有真正改变什么，但自然而然地，这感觉意义重大。因此，诸如“这段感情适合我吗？我快乐吗？我能和这个人结婚吗？我能和这个人共同抚育孩子吗？这就是我为自己想象的吗？”之所有这些问题开始涌现。所以在心理学中，这种体验有一个名字。它被称为“时间路标”。因此，时间路标是时间里的时刻，比如新年、生日、周年纪念日，它们在日常生活流中格外显眼。它们就像精神上的，我不知道，精神上的章节分界线。它们让你真正停下来反思，因为由于它们的意义，会有一种强烈的“之前”和“之后”的对比感。
anniversary, they produced like a psychological fork in the road where big questions and big decisions and doubts are very much amplified by a sense of urgency and a sense of importance. Perhaps you've, you know, you've had these feelings about your relationship for a while, but suddenly you're about to turn 30 or you're seeing friends get married and it feels very important to address them before the new chapter starts. Kind of linked to a quarter life crisis as well. You know, this is when you see a lot of couples break up. It's like, do I want to go into the next chapter with this person? Yes or no. And if the answer is new, will I better get out quick? Another related concept that you may or may not be familiar with is the seven year itch. Now,
因此，像30岁生日、毕业、五周年纪念日这样的事情，会产生一种心理上的十字路口，在这里，重大问题、重大决定和疑虑被紧迫感和重要性大大放大。也许你，你知道，你对这段感情有这种感觉已经有一段时间了，但突然间你就要30岁了，或者你看到朋友们结婚了，在新的篇章开始之前解决这些问题显得非常重要。这也与四分之一人生危机有关。你知道，这就是你看到很多情侣分手的时候。就像是：我想和这个人进入下一个章节吗？是的还是不是。如果答案是否定的，那我最好赶紧抽身离开！另一个你可能熟悉也可能不熟悉的相关的概念是“七年之痒”。现在，
This idea, it actually came from a movie with Marilyn Monroe back in the 50s, which was called The Seven Year Itch. It's not necessarily a scientific term, but colloquially, it kind of describes a feeling of restlessness and unease that people note around the seven year mark of their relationship. It's at seven years around that time that people begin to realize, oh, like, this is my future, where this is end game. They also perhaps start to get lazy in a relationship. They start to realize that the problems they have are probably not going to change.
这个想法实际上来自50年代玛丽莲·梦露主演的一部名为《七年之痒》的电影。这不一定是一个科学术语，但在日常口语中，它大致描述了一种焦躁不安的感觉，人们在感情走到第七个年头左右时会注意到这种感觉。正是在七年左右的这个时候，人们开始意识到：哦，原来这就是我的未来，或者这就是终局。他们也可能开始在感情中变懒。他们开始意识到他们所拥有的问题可能不会改变。
And they break up. If you've been with someone since your late teens, early 20s, that seven-year itch is going to hit in your late 20s right as you're about to enter 30. And unlike people who met later, you do have the existential realization of like, wait, I never really got to know myself, which compounds. the, I guess the fear of staying in the relationship. Basically, you know, people might experience the seven-year itch in their 30s or in their 40s, but they can kind of say, oh, wait, no, like I had time to search around. I had time today. I know this person is right for me because I've seen what else is out there.
然后他们分手了。如果你从十几岁或二十岁出头就和某人在一起，那么七年之痒就会在你快三十岁、正要跨入三十岁门槛时袭来。与那些后来才遇到的人不同，你有一种存在主义的觉悟，比如：等等，我从来没有真正了解过自己，这加剧了。我猜，留在关系中的恐惧。基本上，你知道，人们可能会在30多岁或40多岁时经历七年之痒，但他们可以说，哦，等等，不，就像我有时间到处寻找一样。我有时间去约会。我知道这个人适合我，因为我见识过外面还有什么。
Whereas for you, who may have not dated anyone else or anyone else seriously, the seven-year itch also is kind of a reminder of like, wait, but this is the only person I've really ever loved or really ever known. This is my only serious relationship. Did I make the right decision? So if you're wondering if there's any science behind this, the answer would be, yes, there actually is. There have been a number of studies and statistical analyses that have attempted to confirm or deny the seven-year-itch myth, including one recently that looked at divorce rate data in 2012. They looked at divorce rate data because breakup data is not as available.
然而对你来说，你可能没有和别人约会过，也没有认真和任何人约会过，七年之痒也是一种提醒，比如：等等，但这是我真正爱过或真正了解的唯一一个人。这是我唯一一段认真的感情。我做了正确的决定吗？所以如果你想知道这背后是否有科学依据，答案是：是的，确实有。有许多研究和统计分析试图证实或否认“七年之痒”的神话，其中包括最近一项研究了2012年离婚率数据的研究。他们研究离婚率数据是因为分手数据没那么容易获得。
and what they found was that the average marriage lasts around seven years, the seven-year itch. Another study in Finland in 2018, they also included people who cohabitate as well as being married. They found something a little bit different, but it still kind of confirms what the previous research has had to say. They have found that most marriages end around the two-year mark. That's when the risk of divorce is higher. But they considered how long the average couple dates before they get married. And they found that to be around 4.9 years. So 4.9 plus 2 puts us at 6.9, almost on the dot, seven years.
他们发现的是，平均婚姻持续大约七年——这就是七年之痒。芬兰在2018年的另一项研究中，也将同居的人以及结婚的人都纳了进来。他们发现了一些略有不同，但仍然在某种程度上证实了先前研究结论的东西。他们发现大多数婚姻在大约两年的时间点结束。那是离婚风险最高的时候。但他们考虑了普通情侣在结婚前约会多长时间。他们发现这个时间大约是4.9年。所以4.9加上2，就等于6.9，几乎不偏不倚，正好七年。
It's why, like, this whole idea and this whole theory, and there's definitely more proof that needs to be provided. And it needs to be done in other areas. But this vague idea, this idea of the seven-year itchews. is why some sociologists and maybe we'd call them, I don't know, social activists, they have suggested that if you choose to get married, you should have to renew your vows every seven years, like renewing your license, right? And if you don't, well, the state will just consider you separated. And it stops people from having to go through messy divorces. It allows people to consciously commit to each other over and over again. Basically, the argument is that marriage
这就是为什么，整个想法和整个理论，而且肯定还需要提供更多的证据。并且需要在其他领域进行研究。但这个模糊的想法，七年之痒的想法。正是为什么一些社会学家，也许我们可以称他们为，我不知道，社会活动家，他们建议，如果你选择结婚，你应该每七年续签一次誓言，就像更新你的驾照一样，对吧？如果你不这样做，那么国家就会认为你们分居了。这可以阻止人们经历混乱的离婚。它允许人们一次又一次地有意识地对彼此做出承诺。基本上，争论的焦点是婚姻
shouldn't be a passive legal obligation. And, you know, I, as someone who's quite romantic, I really love this idea. I think it's brilliant. I think that given some of the research and the evidence coming through, perhaps this would make society a little bit healthier and stop people from going through these terrible divorces or feeling like they can't leave their relationship or feeling like they're stuck. It would give us more of a sense of like sometimes relationships aren't meant to last forever and at critical points where you have to either grow or separate, it's something that you should really have to consider rather than just going with the status quo. So I would say this research kind of explains why a lot of people break up at this pivotal time in their 20s, but why do they
不应该只是一种被动的法律义务。而且，你知道，我作为一个相当浪漫的人，我真的很喜欢这个想法。我认为这太棒了。我认为鉴于一些正在涌现的研究和证据，也许这会使社会更健康一点，并阻止人们经历这些可怕的离婚，或者觉得他们无法离开自己的感情，或者觉得自己被困住了。这会给我们带来更多这样的感觉：有时感情并不是注定要永远持续下去的，在你要么成长要么分手的关键节点，这应该是你真正需要考虑的事情，而不是随波逐流。所以我想说，这项研究在某种程度上解释了为什么很多人在20多岁这个关键时期分手，但为什么他们
also suddenly experience a change in personality afterwards? What's with the upheaval, what's with the dramatic shift in lifestyle that accompanies the end of the relationship? Basically, why does this puberty aspect take place? I think the kind of sudden shifts in identity and personality that occur and show up in people after they end a long-term relationship is because I think they're trying to attempt to make up for lost time by doing all the things that their relationship status previously prevented them from doing. And doing all the things that they see is stereotypically single behaviors that they didn't get to do before. It may also be like a rebellion, I guess, against who this relationship made them into.
事后也会突然经历性格上的改变呢？为什么会发生动荡？为什么伴随着关系结束会有生活方式的戏剧性转变？基本上，为什么会出现这种“青春期”的方面？我认为人们在结束一段长期关系后表现出的身份和性格的突然转变，是因为我认为他们试图通过做那些他们的恋爱状态以前阻止他们做的事情来弥补失去的时间。并且做所有他们认为是对刻板的单身行为、而他们以前没有做过的事情。这可能也是一种叛逆，我猜，是对这段感情把他们塑造成什么样的一种叛逆。
So there's this concept in psychology called reactants, which basically explains how when we feel our freedom has been restricted, in this case by our past relationship, we sometimes swing really hard in the opposite direction to reclaim that freedom. And it's why someone who felt romantically safe. stifled might suddenly become wildly romantically adventurous or why someone who felt neglected might suddenly chase really intense attraction and love bombing and the highs of a situation ship. They are reacting against an external pressure that they felt restricted them. And because they haven't really had this kind of freedom for a while, maybe they just go a little
所以在心理学中有一个概念叫做“抗拒”，它基本上解释了当我们的自由感受到限制时（在这种情况下是被过去的感情限制），我们有时会拼命向相反的方向摆动以夺回这种自由。这就是为什么一个在浪漫上感到安全、窒息的人可能会突然在浪漫上变得极其爱冒险，或者为什么一个感到被忽视的人可能会突然去追求极其强烈的人体吸引力、轰炸式的爱意以及“情窦初开”的高峰。他们是在反抗让他们感到受限制的外部压力。而且因为他们已经有一段时间没有这种自由了，也许他们只是做得有点过头了。
bit overboard. I don't see the harm in it. I think, you know what, have your fun if you feel like you missed out. If you feel like that's something that's weighing heavy on you, like you should be able to have those fun experiences, but also beyond reactance, you know, the end of a significant long-term relationship does leave you with a major identity void. You've probably forgotten who you are without this person. If your 20s were built around the idea of a future with someone, if your interests were shaped by theirs, if every core memory, they're in it,
我看不出这有什么害处。我认为，你知道吗，如果你觉得自己错过了，那就去尽情享受吧。如果你觉得这是一件让你感到沉重的事情，你应该能够拥有那些有趣的经历。但超越抗拒心理，你知道，一段重要的长期关系的结束确实会留下一个重大的身份真空。如果没有这个人，你可能已经忘记了你是谁。如果你的20岁是围绕着与某人共创未来的想法建立的，如果你的兴趣是被他们的兴趣所塑造的，如果每个核心记忆里都有他们，
all your friends, they're the same, they know everything about you. Stepping back into the world without them can feel very lonely and very empty, not just because you miss them, but because this part of you is disrupted. And so sometimes these behaviors, these wild adventures, they are in response to that void. They're us trying to stack up experiences that could provide us with meaning, with purpose, show us who we are, and us psychologically revealing so that we can figure out who am I? Who am I without this person? I have to do some major experimentation, some major risk taking to speed up this process. These kind of behaviors may also be a little bit of a distraction in the beginning, a comfort in a very lonely period, but also a way to say,
你所有的朋友都是一样的，他们对你的一切都了如指掌。没有他们重新踏入这个世界会让人感到非常孤独和空虚，不仅是因为你想念他们，还因为你身上的一部分被打乱了。所以有时这些行为，这些疯狂的冒险，是对那个真空的回应。它们是我们试图积累能够为我们提供意义、目的、向我们展示我们是谁的经历，以及我们在心理上的重塑，以便我们能够弄清楚：我是谁？没有这个人，我是谁？我必须进行一些重大的实验，一些重大的冒险来加速这个过程。这些行为在一开始也可能有点像一种分散注意力的方式，在非常孤独的时期给予安慰，但也是一种表达方式，
like, hey, look, I can do this on my own. I can have fun. I am independent. I'm new. I'm different now. This relationship didn't define me. But eventually there will come a time where you have to confront the fact that a big part of your life is over and make sense of what's left over in the emotional rubble and that can bring some really complicated emotions. As much as you're having heaps of fun, you're solo traveling, you're dyeing your hair, you're sleeping around, you're going on dates and you never thought this was going to be part of your life as much as that is so fun. I do think that there are these moments of pause where we kind of think,
就像：嘿，看，我自己也能做到。我可以玩得开心。我是独立的。我是崭新的。我现在不一样了。这段感情并没有定义我。但最终会有一个时刻，你必须面对这样一个事实：你生命中的一大部分已经结束了，去理清情感废墟中剩下的是什么，这会带来一些非常复杂的感情。尽管你玩得很开心，独自旅行，染头发，和不同的人上床，去约会，而你从没想过这会成为你生活的一部分，尽管这很有趣。我确实认为会有这样的停顿时刻，我们不禁会想：
wait, I can't get that time back. Am I actually going to find someone better? Like, wait, did I make a mistake? And I think those thoughts and those fears deserve the very own section. So we're going to devote the next part of this episode to these internal conflicts, but also how to embrace this new chapter ahead of you, how to find peace with the relationship ending, how to just have more fun with being single,
等等，我拿不回那些时间了。我真的能找到更好的人吗？等等，我是不是犯了错误？我认为这些想法和恐惧值得拥有它们自己的专属部分。所以我们将把这期节目的下一部分专门用于探讨这些内心冲突，以及如何拥抱你面前的新篇章，如何与关系的结束达成和解，如何更好地享受单身生活，
even when it feels kind of terrible at times. So stay with us after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
即使有时感觉真的很糟糕。在短暂的休息后，请继续收听我们节目。《2%》！这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养坚韧的精神、强健的体魄以及建立心理韧性。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，透过那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules. that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊恐不安的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你终将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即字母T-W-O-Persent，在I-Hart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上均可收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，永远不要招惹乡下姑娘。玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
法则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在新一季的《女朋友们》中，天啊，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想这怎么会发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在意。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼，绝不。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you. you're thinking, what the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两下小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和金姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意谈论当天的快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
所以我开始看到一条主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有哪个年份比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了表彰心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。
you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app.
你觉得活着的时候做一个好人很重要吗？还是说你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是单纯地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开免费的iHeart Radio App。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. As humans, I've definitely noticed this strange, tendency to only see growth as the addition of things, not so much the subtraction, you know, gaining more money, gaining more friends, gaining more followers, gaining skills, gaining more accomplishments. There is just as much expansion in subtraction, particularly the subtraction of the wrong relationship. And my use of that word subtraction is deliberate because it's a subtraction. It's not a failure. It's not a loss. It is a beginning as much as it is an end. I read a paper recently that essentially confirmed this idea that leaving the wrong relationship,
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。作为人类，我绝对注意到了一种奇怪的倾向，即只把成长视为事物的增加，而不是减少，你知道，获得更多的钱，获得更多的朋友，获得更多的粉丝，获得技能，获得更多的成就。减少同样蕴含着巨大的拓展，尤其是剔除错误的感情。我使用“减少”这个词是有意的，因为它是一种减少。它不是失败。它不是损失。它既是一个结束，也是一个开始。我最近读了一篇论文，基本上证实了这样一个观点：离开错误的感情，
even if it was a good relationship, will significantly improve your life. But you have to get through this kind of tough period first, this period of heartache, but also a secondary existential layer. For starters, you know, the end of a long-term relationship, in your 20s, and especially in your late 20s, is going to bring about some milestone anxiety. And milestone anxiety, if you haven't listened to our episode on this, is this very intense pressure to reach traditional life milestones at specific times. And those specific times are subconsciously impressed on us by society without us even realizing.
即使那是一段不错的感情，也会显著改善你的生活。但你必须先度过这段艰难的时期，这段心碎的时期，还有次生的存在主义层面。首先，你知道，结束一段长期的感情，在20多岁时，尤其是20多岁快结束时，会带来一些里程碑焦虑。而里程碑焦虑，如果你没有听过我们关于这个话题的那集节目，就是一种在特定时间达到传统人生里程碑的非常强烈的心态压力。而这些特定的时间是在我们甚至没有意识到的情况下，由社会潜移默化地印在我们的脑海里的。
Some of the ones that we typically think of and buy into without even realizing is to graduate by the time you're 22, to be married and have a house. by 30, to have kids by 35. And if you're not doing that, if you're not hitting those targets at that exact time, people will think, oh, wow, well, you had kids too late or you had kids too young. Oh, well, you graduated too early or you graduated too late. Like, something's wrong with you. You haven't found your partner yet, but if you find your partner at 21, you know, you wasted, you wasted the opportunity to meet other people, but if you find them at 31 or, well, what was wrong with you? It took you some extra time. Like, it's so frustrating and it's, you're, you,
我们通常会想到并且在甚至没有意识到时就全盘接受的一些里程碑包括：在22岁前毕业，30岁前结婚并拥有房子，35岁前生孩子。如果你没有这样做，如果你没有在那个确切的时间达到这些目标，人们就会想：哦，天哪，好吧，你生孩子太晚了，或者你生孩子太早了。哦，好吧，你毕业太早了，或者你毕业太晚了。就像，你有什么毛病。你还没找到伴侣，但如果你在21岁时找到伴侣，你知道，你浪费了，你错过了结识其他人的机会，但如果你在31岁时找到，好吧，你有什么毛病？这花你额外的时间。就像，这太令人沮丧了，而且，你，
makes us so uneasy and it's so restrictive and it gives us a real sense of being left behind. I think as well as people seemingly move forward in their serious relationships, you've just taken the biggest step back possible. You know, you left your relationship. And so the comparison is deeply destructive and is deeply, I guess, contrasting, right? Like this person and people that you look at are going to seem so different to you because you did make such a giant leap and you did take such a leap of faith, but I want you to remember this. You have no idea how many people are staying with someone out of fear of not finding anyone better. You have no idea how many of these people that you're comparing yourself to are staying with someone they don't actually
让我们如此不安，它又如此具有限制性，给我们一种被抛在后面的强烈感觉。我也认为，当人们在他们的严肃恋爱关系中看似向前迈进时，你却刚刚迈出了可能的最大退步。你知道，你离开了你的感情。因此，这种对比是极具破坏性的，也是极其强烈的反差，对吧？就像这个人以及你看待的人对你来说会显得如此不同，因为你确实做出了如此巨大的飞跃，你也确实凭信念迈出了这一步，但我希望你记住这一点。你根本不知道有多少人仅仅因为害怕找不到更好的人而留在某人身边。你根本不知道你在与之比较的这些人中有多少人正和他们其实并不那么喜欢的人在一起，因为他们害怕孤独。回头走错路总是更好的，哪怕你已经领先了数英里。回头总是、总是比继续往前走要好。
really enjoy that much because they're scared of being lonely. And it is always better to turn back down the wrong road, even if you are miles ahead. It is always always better to turn around rather than to keep going. You know, you did not let the fear of not finding someone better allow you to stay with someone who wasn't right, regardless of what others are doing. And I want you to remember, you know, you are the only one who has to live fully with your decisions. And so choosing what was best for you will always be the right call, even if it isn't what other people expect, even if it seemingly puts you behind or disappoints people, even if it's scary for now, you have saved yourself a lot of disappointment and pain in the future.
你知道，你没有让“找不到更好的人”的恐惧阻碍你和一个不合适的人在一起，不管别人在做什么。我希望你记住，你知道，你是唯一一个必须完全承担自己决定后果的人。因此，选择最适合你的事情永远都是正确的决定，即使它不是别人所期望的，即使它看起来让你落后了或者让人失望，即使现在感觉很可怕，你也为自己省去了未来许多的失望和痛苦。
by making a hard decision when, you know, making a hard decision when it would have been very easy to make the wrong one. I think the second existential thing that feels paralyzing in the wake of a long-term relationship breakup is this idea that you wasted your time. You spent three, five, seven years, maybe even longer with someone who didn't end up being the one. And you could have used that time finding the one. You could have used that time exploring and now you have to do a, it now. Now you have to do it as someone who is old, which I think is, you're not old. You're really
通过在可以轻松做出错误决定的时候，做出艰难的决定。我认为，在一段长期恋爱关系结束后，第二件让人感到麻木的存在主义事情是这种“你浪费了时间”的想法。你花了三、五年、七年，甚至更长时间和一个最终没能成为对的人在一起。你本可以把这些时间用来寻找真命天子。你本可以把这些时间用来探索，而现在你必须去做。现在你必须以一个老年人的身份去做，我觉得，你并不老。你真的
not old. You're still a child. But there's this weird sense that the time before was more valuable than the time you have ahead. Like the time you spent in that relationship when you were young is more valuable than the time you're going to spend single now that you're older. I think because we have a real anti-aging philosophy and belief system in this society. And so you're young. And so you're younger years, their scene is seen as very, very important and impressive and full of all these experiences and where all the fun is. And so if you wasted that on a relationship, well, then you've got the short, straught. Like, you now have to be single in a less fun period, a less fun time. And that is just total crap. Like, it's just total, total crap. You still have
不老。你还是个孩子。但有一种奇怪的感觉，认为之前的时间比你面前的时间更有价值。就像你在年轻时在那段感情中花费的时间，比你现在老了之后单身时花费的时间更有价值。我认为是因为我们在这个社会中有一种反老龄化的哲学和信仰体系。所以你是年轻的。因此，你更年轻的岁月被视为非常、非常重要、令人印象深刻，充满了所有这些经历，并且是所有乐趣所在。所以如果你把这些浪费在了一段感情上，那么你就吃亏了。你现在不得不在一个不那么有趣的时期、一个不那么有趣的时间段里单身。这简直是胡扯。这简直、简直是胡扯。你仍然有
so much time ahead of you. In fact, you have so much more time than if you'd stayed and been miserable and you have so many more good memories to make and you have so many more opportunities. This is not a loss. This is not a deficit. This is an incredible gift. And people meet their soulmates at 37. They meet them at 40. They're married and have kids by 42. People meet their soulmates at 60. You know, true love doesn't just find you when you're young. It's not just something to tick off the bucket list before you turn 30. And I'm glad that you hopefully somewhere in your heart know that. and that you didn't follow a timeline and didn't feel like you had to stay on a timeline more than you had to value your own happiness.
你的前方还有大把的时间。事实上，比起你留下来饱受折磨，你拥有更多的时间，你有更多美好的回忆去创造，你有更多的机遇。这不是损失。这不是亏欠。这是一份不可思议的礼物。人们在37岁遇到灵魂伴侣。他们在40岁遇到。他们在42岁结婚生子。人们在60岁遇到灵魂伴侣。你知道的，真爱不仅会在你年轻时降临。这不只是你在30岁之前要从心愿清单上勾掉的一项任务。我很高兴你希望在内心深处的某个地方知道这一点，而且你没有盲目追随时间表，也没有觉得自己必须死守时间表，而不是去珍视自己的幸福。
But I totally get it. I feel like the sense of loss and the sense of disruption is very, very strong. But it's this kind of thinking, this thinking of, I'm my God, I'm never going to find anyone better. I'm never going to find love. I've already put all this time into this person that gets us stuck in a sunk cost mentality. and that gets us staying in places we ultimately don't want to be. Here's what I have to say to this.
但我完全理解。我觉得这种失落感和颠覆感非常、非常强烈。但正是这种想法，这种“天哪，我再也找不到比他更好的人了，我再也找不到爱了，我已经在这个人身上投入了这么多时间”的想法，让我们陷入了沉没成本的心态中，让我们留在了那些我们内心深处并不想呆的地方。对于这一点，我想说的是：
If you feel like you've wasted your time, if you feel like you're not going to get your youth back, if you feel like you wish you had known better and left earlier, how do you know that it would have been better if this relationship hadn't happened? How do you know you wouldn't have been in a worse relationship or wouldn't be feeling just as lost? How do you even know that you would have met someone? Maybe you could have spent that whole time single,
如果你觉得自己浪费了时间，如果你觉得你再也找不回青春，如果你觉得自己宁愿当初更清醒一点、早点离开，你怎么知道如果没有发生这段感情事情就会更好呢？你怎么知道你不会陷入一段更糟糕的感情，或者不会感到同样迷茫呢？你怎么知道你就一定能遇到某个人呢？也许你本可以把这段时间全用来单身，
and yeah, it would have been fine and it would have been great, but you wouldn't have learnt some of the lessons that you did learn. You wouldn't know now what kind of person is better for you. You wouldn't know now how to trust your gut. You wouldn't know how to move through pain and uncertainty. You've learnt love. You've learnt valuable relationship skills. You've learned more about yourself, regardless of it not working out. And you would be so surprised of how thankful I am, actually, of the times that I've previously had my heartbroken because in hindsight I can see that that is exactly what needed to happen. And I can see that despite all the pain and gosh, it was painful, it was the best thing possible
是的，那也没问题，那也会很棒，但你就不会学到那些你真正学到的教训。你现在就不会知道什么样的人更适合你。你现在就不会知道如何相信自己的直觉。你不会知道如何度过痛苦和不确定性。你学会了爱。你学会了宝贵的恋爱技巧。无论这段感情是否修成正果，你都对自己有了更多的了解。你会非常惊讶于我实际上是多么感激我过去心碎的时刻，因为事后看来我能看到这正是需要发生的事情。而且我能看到，尽管经历了所有的痛苦——天哪，真的很痛苦——这对我来说已经是可能发生的最美好的事情了。
for me. I have friends who have married their versions of my ex. I have friends who have married the person that they doubted all along was right for them. And you know what? Some of them are happy and some of them are okay. but some of them are also like I really, I'm in it now and I care about this person and we're going to build a family together, but I wish I'd waited a little bit longer. I wish that I'd learned more about myself. So it's not a failure. It's not a waste to walk away from the wrong person. It is a gift. This is something that you will end up valuing so much. This is something that you will end up being so immensely grateful to yourself for.
我有朋友嫁给了我前任那种类型的人。我有朋友嫁给了他们一直怀疑并不适合自己的人。你知道吗？他们中有的人很幸福，有的人也还过得去，但也有的人会说：“我现在陷进去了，我在乎这个人，我们要一起建立一个家庭，但我真希望自己能再多等一会儿。我真希望自己能多了解自己一些。”所以，离开错误的人并不是失败，也不是浪费。这是一份礼物。这是你最终会无比珍视的东西。这是你最终会对自己充满无限感激的事情。
So how do we actually embrace this new phase for ourselves? I think the first thing is lean into the puberty part, lean into being a little bit wild, lean into going a little bit crazy, lean into doing just things that you wanted to do that you couldn't do in your relationship, even if they feel scary or risky or embarrassing. You know, healing will come, sadness will come. Like it's going to happen. So just ride the highs whilst you can and whilst you want to. And then when the lows come, like lean into them as well.
那么，我们该如何真正拥抱属于自己的这个新阶段呢？我认为第一件事是，去享受那种“叛逆期”的状态，去享受一点点野性的状态，去享受一点点疯狂的状态，去做那些你想做但在恋爱中却无法去做的事情，哪怕它们让你感到害怕、冒险或尴尬。你知道的，疗愈会到来，悲伤会到来。这些都是必然会发生的。所以，只要还能做到、只要你想这么做，就去尽情体验快乐的高峰吧。然后，当低谷来临时，也去勇敢地接纳它们。
You know, I always say if you embrace the pain fully for six months, you save yourself from two years of lingering suffering. It's better to kind of lean into it and get it, not out of the way, but just let it take control for a little while, rather than trying to fight it off for as long as possible and realize that that's a losing game. I also want you to keep contact to a minimum. them. I know that if you have been with this person for a long time, if you live with them, if you have a pet with them, if you have all the same friends, that is very, very hard, which is why I don't say, don't talk to them at all. But really use your judgment here. You know that the more you talk to them, the harder it is for your brain to unlearn their presence in your life. There
你知道的，我总是说，如果你完全拥抱痛苦六个月，你就能免去两年的挥之不去的痛苦。最好还是去经历它，把它——倒也不是说抛诸脑后，而是让它接管你的一小段时间，而不是尽可能长时间地去抗拒它，然后意识到那是一场注定要输的游戏。我还希望你把联系降到最低。我知道，如果你和这个人在一起很久了，如果你和他们住在一起，如果你和他们养了宠物，如果你有共同的朋友，这会非常非常困难，这也是为什么我没有说“完全不要和他们说话”。但在这里一定要用你的理智。你知道的，你和他们聊得越多，你的大脑就越难抹去他们在你生活中的存在。
is the saying neurons that fire together, wire together. And there is all these pathways in your brain right now associated with this person that are very entrenched. And the more you continue to stay in contact with them and be around them and remember all the funny, quirky things they did, the harder it is for those pathways to be paved over, the harder it is for new pathways to blossom in their place. So please keep contact to a minimum. Don't check up on them through friends. Get off social media for a while. Do a big closure chat right at the beginning, give back all their stuff and then focus on you. This is you. This is your new chapter. Like this is your time, your period. This is like the year for you. They don't need to be part of it,
有句名言叫“一起被激活的神经元会连在一起”。此时此刻你大脑中所有与这个人相关的神经回路都根深蒂固。你越是继续与他们保持联系、在他们身边、回想起他们做过的所有搞笑古怪的事情，那些神经回路就越难被覆盖，新的神经回路就越难在它们的位置上绽放。所以请把联系降到最低。不要通过朋友去打听他们的消息。暂时远离社交媒体。在刚开始时做一次彻底的告别交谈，把他们的东西全还回去，然后专注于你自己。这是你。这是你的新篇章。这就像是属于你的时间，你的时期。这就像是属于你的一年。他们不需要成为其中的一部分，
even though they might feel and might feed into this real deep nostalgia and love. And even though it's hard to disentangle yourself, like you need to make smart decisions for what you want in the future. And it's going to be harder for you to move on fully and not feel like this was a bad decision if you keep letting them back in for a few seconds, a few minutes at a time. I also want you to go and do all your doctor's appointments. I want you to go to the dentist. I want you to get your hair cut. I want you to go and get like a physical, going at your bloods done, just do everything in
尽管他们可能会带来并助长这种内心深处强烈的怀旧感和爱意。尽管要把自己抽离出来很难，但为了你对未来的期望，你需要做出明智的决定。如果你一次又一次地让他们回到你的生活中哪怕几秒钟、几分钟，你就会更难彻底走出来，也更难不觉得这是一个糟糕的决定。我还想让你去做所有的体检。我想让你去看牙医。我想让你去剪个头发。我想让你去做个全面体检，去查个血，在身体保养方面做好一切准备，以健康的体魄开启这个新篇章，让你感觉：“好吧，很酷。我为这段关系的结束打上了句号，这就是全新的开始。”感觉自己很健康，状态很好。我正在做所有我需要做的事，以确保自己处于最佳状态。去买一本崭新的笔记本，开始写下你对接下来这个新篇章的所有感受。
terms of physical maintenance to really start this new chapter with a clean bill of health to feel like, okay, cool. I've bookmarked the end of this relationship. and this is the new beginning. Like, I feel healthy. I feel well. I'm doing everything that I need to do to make sure I'm in the best place I can be. And get like a fresh notebook and just start writing down everything that you're feeling about
去感受这是多么神圣的一件事，去感受你将学到多少东西。把它当作一本分手日记、心碎日记、感情结束日记。60年后或40年后，你会在某个盒子里找到它，能够去追忆往事，为自己能在明知是正确时机时勇敢离开而感到骄傲，或者只是让自己明白，你可以承受痛苦，你可以承受艰难的事情。如果你突然为单身感到难过，我希望你记住，仅仅因为你感到难过，并不意味着那段感情就是对的。你知道的，感觉并不是现实的全部反映。
this next chapter. Like, lean into how sacred this is, lean into how much you're going to learn. Make it like a diary of a breakup, a diary of heartache, a diary of this relationship ending, that in 60 years' time or 40 years' time, you're. find in a box somewhere and get to reminisce on and get to feel proud of yourself that you walked away when you knew it was the right time or just allow yourself to see that you can endure pain and you can endure hard things. If you're suddenly sad about being single, I want you to remember that just because you're sad doesn't mean it was the right relationship. You know, feelings aren't a
它们无法预测未来。它们并不总是表明你做错了选择。它们只是对某种选择做出的反应。请记住，这里的两个选项都会很艰难。留在那种关系里会很艰难。离开也很艰难。所以感到内心冲突是正常的，但要知道，偶尔想起他们，偶尔脑海中突然浮现他们的身影，偶尔想念他们并感到心碎，这并不意味着你需要和他们复合。这只是你身体对悲伤的自然反应。这只是在适应新的事物。请不要对这些反应做过多的过度解读。
total reflection of reality. They can't predict things. They are not always an indication that you made the wrong choice. They had just a response to a choice. And remember both options here were going to be hard. Staying in that relationship would have been hard. Leaving is hard. And so it's okay to be conflicted, but know that randomly thinking of them, randomly having them pop up in your mind, randomly missing them and feeling devastated, that is not an indication that you need to get back with them. This is just your body's natural response to grief. And it's just, adjusting to something new. Please don't read anything more into that than it is.
有一个非常棒的小技巧，我在上一段感情结束后亲自使用过。当我为单身感到非常难过、并对单身感到世界末日般的绝望时，我使用了“两栏对比法”。这是一个认知行为疗法（CBT）的技巧，也就是在一个栏目里写下你对关系结束或单身的负面想法或负面信念，然后在右边的栏目里，也就是另一个栏目里，用一句积极且真实的陈述来反驳它。所以在左边的栏目里，你可能会写：我再也找不到像他们这样的人了。而在右边的栏目里，你写：我可能找不到像他们一样的人，但我会找到更适合我的人。
A really great trick that I personally used after my last relationship ended. When I was like feeling very sad about being single and was feeling very doomsday about it, it was called the two-column technique. And it's a CBT trick, so a cognitive behavioral therapy trick where you write down your negative thoughts or your negative beliefs about the relationship ending or being single in one column. and then on the right column, the other column, you counter it with a positive true statement. So in the left column you might write, I'm never going to find someone like them. And in the right column you write, I won't find someone like them, but I'll find someone better suited.
在左边的栏目里，你可能会写：这种痛苦永远不会结束。在右边的栏目里，你写：我知道痛苦不会永远持续下去。我知道人类的情感不是这样运作的，总有一天我会感激这段旅程中艰难的部分，因为它正引领我走向更好的地方。会有很多信念和恐惧涌现，因为这一切都是崭新的、生疏的、艰难的。不要让它们成为你唯一的知识和现实来源。不要让它们把你带回那些你内心深处明知无法满足你的事物中去。所以这个技巧非常有用。还要记住，前六个月总是最艰难的。
In the left column you might write, this pain will never end. In the right column you write, I know the pain won't last forever. I know that that's not how human emotion works and that one day I'll be thankful for this hard part of the journey because it's leading me somewhere better. There's going to be a lot of beliefs and fears that come up because this is new and this is raw and this is hard. Don't let them be the sole source of knowledge and reality for you. Don't let them lead you back to something that you know in your heart of hearts wasn't fulfilling. So that trick is incredibly useful. Also remember, the first six months will always be the toughest.
即使你过得很开心，也会有黑暗的日子。你会慢慢地、切实地感觉好起来。未来总会有一天，你会醒来时不再立刻想起他们，你能去约会而不会马上把对方作比较。时间有一种神奇的治愈力量，它会悄悄向你袭来。它会一点一点、慢慢地发生，然后一切就会豁然开朗，你会感觉好很多，并准备好去寻找一段新的、认真的感情。这也顺理成章地让我进入了大家常问的下一个问题：我怎么知道自己已经准备好重新开始认真约听了？
Even if you are having fun with it, there will be dark days. Slowly but surely you will feel better. and there is a time coming up in the future where you're going to wake up and not immediately think about them and you're going to be able to go on a date and not immediately compare them and time has this funny way of like of healing you and sneaking up on you it's going to happen slowly slowly slowly and then all at once you will feel a whole lot better and you'll feel ready to find someone new and serious and that kind of brings me to into the next question people ask me, when do I know I'm ready to seriously date again?
听着，我无法给你一个具体的周数。我无法给你一个具体的月数或天数。这非常主观，但我可以给你一种作为标志的感觉。当你想到他们时，你不想哭了，不想给他们打电话了，不想报复他们了。你不想让他们知道你在约会。这才是你被允许重新开始约会的时候。当你对关系的结束感到更深层的平静和清醒，而不是痛苦和狂怒时，这才是你可以约会的时候。另外还有两个问题要问问自己：你觉得自己足够坚强去面对拒绝或事情没有成功吗？你是否已经从失恋中恢复得足够好，以至于如果有什么新的潜在可能降临到你头上、如果一个新的人出现，你能全心全意地投入进去？
Listen, I can't give you a specific number of weeks. I can't give you a specific number of months or days. It's very objective, but I can give you a feeling that works as a sign. So when you think about them and you don't want to cry, you don't want to call them, you don't want to get back at them. You don't want them to know that you're dating. That's when you are allowed to start dating again. When you feel a deeper sense of peace and clarity over the relationship ending rather than pain and fury, that's when you can date again. Two other questions to ask yourself, do you feel strong enough to handle rejection or things not working out? And do you feel over your breakup enough that you could be all in with someone if something new that had potential landed in your lap if a new
你准备好了吗？你知道的，自我完善是一个永无止境的过程。只要你花了一些时间真正了解自己，只要你对自己的需求保持诚实，只要你知道你以前在哪些方面做出了妥协、并且知道哪些错误你不会再犯，你就准备好去约会了。去享受其中的乐趣吧。
person came along? Would you be ready? You know, work. Working on yourself is a never-ending process. And as long as you have taken some time to really know yourself, as long as you are being honest about what you want, as long as you know what you previously compromised on and you know what mistakes you won't make again, you're ready to date. Go and have some fun with it.
你知道的，你已经经历过长期恋爱了。你已经体验过承诺的爱。去看看可能还存在着哪些其他形式的爱吧。假设一下，每当我刚单身或者对单身感觉糟糕透顶时，我总是会这么想：你知道的，如果我知道自己将在六个月后遇到灵魂伴侣，在此之前我想体验什么？这真的是一个超级棒的想法和假设，它能帮助你按照你所设想的这段时期来生活。正是这六个月
You know, you've done the long-term relationship thing. You have known, committed love. Just see what other versions of love might be out there. You know, hypothetically, I always, think this when I'm freshly single or feeling terrible about being single, I always used to think, you know, if I knew I was going to meet my soulmate in six months time, what would I want to experience before them? And that is a really great way and a really great hypothetical that will help you live your life in accordance with how you imagined this era being. And it's this six month
的时期、这个假设中的六个月窗口期，让你看到了单身是多么难得的机遇，并让你真正去思考这个问题：“我想从中得到什么？我该如何最大化地利用这段时间？”好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但只需一会儿我们就会回来，带来一些听众朋友们提出来的精彩问题和两难困境，关于长期关系的结束、关于分手、关于在经历了一些重大的结束之后我们所经历的这个“第二青春期”。所以请继续收听我们节目。我们在短暂休息后马上回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇特现代世界中培养心理韧性、
period, this hypothetical six-month window that makes you see what an opportunity being single is, and it makes you really pose the question, like, what do I want to get out of this? How can I get the most out of this? Okay, we are going to take a short break, but in just a minute we're going to return with some juicy listener questions and dilemmas about the end of long-term relationships, about breakups, about this second puberty that we go through after this significant end of something significant. So stay with us. We'll be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
体能以及建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和体能专家等人进行对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本身就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题其实都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships,
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即英文单词“Two Percent”，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金规则。规则一，绝对不要去招惹乡村女孩。
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
你在玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。规则二，也绝对不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》这个全新的节目季里……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我说，哦，见鬼，休想。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day,
我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一集中，我们都会精选一个事件，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊关于快克的话题，
but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American
但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条内在脉络了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。所以……。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
欢迎收听我的全新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多极其优秀的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），你们觉得在世期间做一个好人重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你心怀恐惧吗？因为这完全是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你们能真正发自内心地去做一个好人。加入我，我是基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games），让我们在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，就疗愈、成长、父职、
pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. So I think that this topic got the most amount of listener questions that I've ever gotten for an episode. Maybe that is comforting for you. If you're currently going through a breakup in your 20s, there are a lot of people who are going through something quite similar and who have a lot of questions around identity, around loneliness, around being single and how much it sucks, but also how to embrace it. So I've actually ended up choosing, I think, seven listener questions when we normally do four just because there were so many good ones. We're going to start out with this first question.
压力和人生目标展开真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。我想这个话题收到了我做播客以来收到过的最多的听众提问。也许这能带给你一些安慰。如果你目前正处于二十多岁的分手期，有很多人也正在经历非常相似的事情，并且对身份认同、孤独、单身以及单身有多糟糕、但又该如何拥抱单身有着许多疑问。所以我最后挑选了七个听众提问，平时我们一般只选四个，纯粹是因为好问题太多了。我们先从第一个问题开始。
Why do we continue these relationships for longer when we knew it was going nowhere? Why do we continue and stay in long-term relationships in our 20s even when we know they're not the right person? I think that it's really driven by fear and it might not feel like fear in the moment. It might not feel intense, but it is fear. It's a fear of loneliness. It's a fear of regret. The fear of regret is really the big one. I think that a lot of us don't know whether it's intuition or anxiety that is driving the car.
为什么当我们明明知道感情走投无路时，还要把这些关系维持更久？为什么我们在二十多岁时，即使明知对方不是对的人，还要继续维持长期恋爱关系？我认为这主要是由恐惧驱动的，而且在当时的感觉可能并不像是恐惧。它可能感觉不那么强烈，但它确实是恐惧。是对孤独的恐惧。是对遗憾的恐惧。对遗憾的恐惧其实才是真正的主导因素。我认为我们很多人都分不清到底是直觉还是焦虑在掌控方向盘。
And so when we have someone who is good, not great, we think, well, if I walk away and I realize he was actually amazing and it was actually my anxiety all along, what if I can't get that relationship back and I regret leaving them? What if I can't find someone better? It's this idea of like, is this it? And if this is it, I don't want to walk away from this person. I don't want to be single. I don't want to realize that I made a huge mistake.
所以当我们身边有一个人还不错、但又没那么好时，我们会想：好吧，如果我走开，然后发现他其实真的很棒，其实一直以来都是我的焦虑在作祟，如果我找不回那段感情并且后悔离开他怎么办？如果我找不到更好的人怎么办？这种想法就是：“难道就这样了吗？如果这就是全部，我不想离开这个人。我不想单身。我不想意识到自己犯了一个巨大的错误。”
I also think that it's us delaying the pain. Breaking up with someone is like standing at the start of the marathon and being like, okay, I've got to do this and knowing it's going to hurt and knowing that it's going to suck and knowing that you have to do it anyways. It's this huge feeling of like, oh my God, I'm signing up for something significant and I'm signing up for, like I'm subjecting myself to a painful reality for the next however many months. And, you know, as humans, we want to avoid that sometimes. But I always say this, you know, avoiding pain now is just delay pain and dissatisfaction into the future.
我也觉得这是我们在拖延痛苦。和某人分手就像是站在马拉松的起跑线上，心想：“好吧，我必须这么做”，明知这会很痛，明知这会很糟，但你知道你无论如何都必须去做。这种感觉非常强烈，就像是：“天哪，我在为一件重大的事情做准备，我在为自己接下来的好几个月里将不得不承受痛苦的现实做准备。”而且，作为人类，我们有时会想要逃避这一点。但我总是这样说：现在逃避痛苦，只是把痛苦和不满推迟到了未来。
And if this person is meant to be with you when you do break up, you will find your way back together. I promise you. I promise you you will. You will find your way back together. because if you break up with them and you're like, wow, like, I really miss them and they're like, I really miss you too. You know, maybe that's the confirmation you need. And if you break up with them and then neither of you really miss each other or neither of you really feel like you're meant to be back together, then it's not meant to be. Also, I just think that it shouldn't take breaking up
如果这个人命中注定要和你在一起，当你分手后，你们会重新走到一起的。我向你保证。我向你保证会的。你们会重新找到彼此。因为如果你和他们分手，然后你觉得：“哇，我真的很想念他们”，而他们也觉得：“我也真的很想念你”，你知道的，也许这就是你需要的确认。如果你和他们分手了，然后你们俩都没有真正想念对方，或者你们俩都不觉得注定应该复合，那么这就不是命中注定。另外，我只是觉得，不应该非得走到分手这一步，
with someone to realize that you want them in your life. And you really only get one, shot at life and do you really want to spend it with someone who you were not entirely excited about and who was not entirely excited by you? I'm not saying you have to listen to every single doubt that comes through your head about a relationship because I know sometimes they're definitely fueled by anxiety and worry and fear and all these other things that might be misplaced but if you look at them and you don't feel excited and proud to be with them, I don't think you should be with them. All right, the second question, should I reach out to check on them after not talking for a year or not?
才能意识到你希望这个人留在你的生命里。你的一生真的只有一次机会，难道你真的想和一个你并非完全为之兴奋、而对方也并非完全为你而兴奋的人共度余生吗？我不是说你必须听从脑海中关于一段关系的所有质疑，因为我知道有时它们绝对是由焦虑、担忧、恐惧以及其他所有可能错置的情绪所驱动的；但如果你看着他们，却感觉不到和他们在一起的兴奋和骄傲，我觉得你就不应该和他们在一起。好的，第二个问题：在断联一年之后，我该不该联系对方去看看他们过得怎么样？
No, no, you should not. That's going to be my blanket answer. I will provide some more nuance, though. I really need you to question your intentions. What are you really trying to get out of this conversation? What do you really need to know from them that's going to help you in the future? If this person is no longer in your life and if you believe, they don't have a place in your future.
不，不，你不应该。这就是我的标准答案。不过，我会提供一些更细腻的看法。我真的需要你拷问一下自己的真实意图。你究竟想从这次对话中得到什么？你到底需要从他们那里知道什么能对你的未来有所帮助？如果这个人已经不再你的生活中了，如果你坚信他们在你的未来里没有位置，
I think that going and talking to them is you just relapsing. It's you just opening old wounds. I think that it is a challenge that I'm going to sound a bit spiritual, but I really do think that the urge is a challenge that the universe or something has given you to
我认为去找他们谈话，只是你在复发。这只是你在揭开旧伤疤。我认为这是一个挑战，听起来可能会有点精神层面的玄乎，但我真的认为这种冲动是宇宙或其他什么给你的挑战，
say, or your own mind has given you to say, okay, are you really over this person? Here's the last hurdle. Like, don't do the check-in. Don't do the check-in. It's just, I think, the final battle the final frontier of you getting over them and you've done so much work it is going to bring you back it is going to make you remember them and feel nostalgic and miss them so please don't do it
或者说是你自己的内心给你的挑战，在问你：“好吧，你真的彻底放下这个人了吗？这是最后的难关。”不要去打听消息。不要去打听消息。我认为这只是你放下他们之路上最后的战役、最后的边疆。你已经做了那么多的努力，这会把你拉回去，会让你记起他们、感到怀旧并开始想念他们，所以请不要这么做。
you have done too much work up to this point to let this undo it all i understand that you probably very sad about the idea that this person is never going to be in your life again and is gone from your life and that's really, really devastating at times, but they're not gone. Like, they taught you a lot of lessons. You still have all the memories. Maybe one day you'll run into each other in the street and it will be beautiful and that will be your closure. But for now, don't message them. Don't check in. All right. Question number three. I feel pressured by my biological clock to stay with my current partner. Is there a way to get over this? I definitely understand this.
你为了走到这一步已经付出了太多努力，别让这一举动前功尽弃。我理解你可能会为“这个人再也不会出现在你的生命中、已经从你的生活中消失了”这种想法感到非常难过，有时这真的非常、非常令人心碎，但他们并没有消失。他们教给你很多人生课。你依然拥有所有的回忆。也许有一天你们会在街头偶遇，那将是一段美好的经历，那将是你们的句号。但现在，不要给他们发信息。不要去打听。好的。第三个问题：由于生物钟的压力，我感到必须和现任伴侣在一起。有什么办法能克服这种心态吗？我完全理解这一点。
I have this huge fear of getting to the point where I want to have kids and something happens that I'm not able to. I think it's a unique fear for women, right? If a family is something that you see in your future, you kind of, you need a guy for that. And hopefully you want someone who you love and who you want a co-parent with and who would be a good parent and a good partner. And so sometimes it can be like, oh my God, like, I need this final puzzle piece. I need this final key.
我也有这种巨大的恐惧，害怕到了想要孩子的年龄却发生什么意外导致自己无法生育。我认为这是女性特有的一种恐惧，对吧？如果组建家庭是你对未来的规划，你某种程度上确实需要一个男人来实现这一点。而且你当然希望有一个你爱的人、一个你想和他共同抚养孩子的人、一个会成为好父母和好伴侣的人。所以有时就会觉得：“天哪，我需要这最后一块拼图。我需要这最后一把钥匙。”
And so if I want a family and this guy he was here is the only way to get one, even if he's not the perfect guy, like, I'll just settle for that. What has brought me a lot of peace, though, is understanding how much technology is out there now. How many women are having children later and later? How many women are having really successful and healthy pregnancies when they're older? You know, it's no longer the norm that people have kids at 22 and 25. Like, there is so much more room for new timelines. You know, my mom had my sister when she was 42.
所以如果我想要一个家庭，而这个男人就是实现这一目标的唯一途径，即使他不是完美先生，我也只好将就了。然而，让我内心获得许多平静的是，我开始了解到现在的科技有多么发达。有多少女性把生育年龄推得越来越晚。有多少女性在年龄较大时依然能拥有非常成功且健康的孕期。你知道的，22岁和25岁生孩子的时代早已不再是常态了。生活有太多空间去开启新的时间线了。你知道的，我妈妈生我妹妹时42岁。
For me, that is 17 years away. That's a whole lifetime. 17 years. Like, I could have a child now and that child almost be an adult and then have another child when that child is like about to graduate high school. I think we need to talk more about, I think we need a better conversation around pregnancy and childbirth, not just being something that is for young women. it's something that is for women in general, even if they are older.
对我来说，那是17年后的事。那是一整个人生。17年。我完全可以现在生一个孩子，当这个孩子快成年时，而在那个孩子即将高中毕业时我再生另一个。我觉得我们需要更多地探讨——我觉得我们需要就怀孕和生育展开更好的讨论，它不应该只是年轻女性的专利，而是所有女性的事，哪怕她们年龄稍大一些。
Like, they can still have successful pregnancies and still have very healthy children. And I sometimes think that this idea of like your biological clock running out is somewhat a way to control women and somewhat a way to make them settle. Just remember that like if you're single right now and you're worried about, oh my God, I'm going to find someone. I'm going to find someone? Like you have so much time. And your relationship status could change at. any moment, at any minute, the right person could walk through the door and you want to make sure that the door is open for them and you haven't closed it because you grabbed the first person who
她们依然可以拥有成功的孕期，生出非常健康的宝宝。有时我觉得“生物钟正在倒计时”这种想法在某种程度上是一种控制女性的方式，也是一种迫使她们将就的手段。请记住，如果你现在单身，并且正担心“天哪，我还能找到人吗？我能找到对象吗？”，你还有大把的时间。你的恋爱状态随时都可能改变，在任何一分钟，对的人都可能推门而入，而你想确保为他们敞开大门，而不是因为你抓住了第一个敲门的人而把门关上了。
came knocking. You know what I mean? Like, I think it's better to wait for the right person who you really want to start a beautiful family with than to just take what's out there. Just enjoy the chapter in right now. There are so many ways to be a mother. Having biological children is one of them, But even if that doesn't happen for you, you know, there are just so many other ways. You can mother friends. You can mother your children's friends. You can mother foster animals. You can be a foster parent.
你知道我的意思吗？我觉得，与其勉强接受现实，不如耐心等待那个真正让你渴望与之组建美丽家庭的对的人。好好享受当下的这个人生阶段吧。成为母亲的方式有很多种。生养自己的生物学孩子是其中之一，但即使这件事没有发生在你身上，你知道的，还有许许多多其他的方式。你可以像母亲一样去关爱朋友。你可以去关爱朋友的孩子。你可以抚养流媒体宠物。你可以成为一名寄养父母。
Like in Australia right now, there's such a need for foster parents. You can adopt children. Like there are so many other ways to be a mother and to have a family these days. Don't let biological clock be the reason that you settle the relationship that you have. Like there's so much science that says, Who you end up with, who you marry, who you have children with is such a predictor of your well-being and your life satisfaction and your life expectancy. So take it seriously. It's very, very important, even if you have other priorities. All right, this fourth question, why did I feel
就像在澳大利亚，现在对寄养父母的需求非常大。你可以领养孩子。如今成为母亲、拥有家庭的方式实在太多了。不要让所谓的生物钟成为你将就一段关系的理由。有很多科学研究表明：你最终和谁在一起、你和谁结婚、你和谁生孩子，是决定你幸福感、生活满意度和预期寿命的重要风向标。所以请认真对待这件事。这非常、非常重要，哪怕你还有其他优先事项。好的，第四个问题：为什么我在结束一段五年的感情后，仅用了一个星期就觉得自己彻底放下了？所以，我不知道这个人是刚刚和伴侣分手，还是已经分手一段时间了。如果你是刚分手，并且觉得自己感觉大好，那可能只是处于震惊之中。我记得我和第一任认真交往的男友分手时，心想：“我放下了。前三个月我挺好的。”然后就像是“轰”的一下，延迟反应才开始发作。所以如果你是刚分手，这可能只是震惊。但如果不是，如果已经过去了一段时间，那可能是因为你其实早就已经死心了。你可能当时并没有意识到。不过你心里其实很清楚这一点：你已经对这段感情死心了。你已经努力尝试过让它维持下去，但行不通。你在还和这个人在一起时就已经找到了内心的释怀。你在分手前就已经在想象分手后自己要做什么了。你已经在学着处理失去对方意味着什么。你已经在想象没有他们的生活会是怎样。你已经在经历这一切之前，基本上就已经把这段心理路程走完了。我想这大概就是解释。这根本不是什么奇怪的事。每个人处理悲伤、失落和心碎的方式大相径庭。但最有可能发生的情况是，要么你处于震惊中，要么你其实在不知不觉中，在身处那段关系的同时就已经完成了释怀并彻底死心了。好的。第五个问题：我担心这种痛苦会一直这么深，而且我永远也找不到像他们那样爱我的人了。我该怎么办？我希望你记住，人类是非常顽强的生物。他们会适应并挺过可怕的事情，你也一定能挺过这一关。目前的伤口还血淋淋的，非常痛，你正处在漫长旅程的起点，但你别无选择，只能走完这段旅程。在刚开始时你会感到愤怒。你会对不得不踏上这段旅程感到愤恨、恼怒和沮丧。你可能会坐在山脚下的路边哭上好几天，但随后你会慢慢找到节奏，开始注意到旅程中美好的事物，你会意识到这段经历其实真的在教给你很多东西、在让你变得坚强，很快你就会为了自己而走在旅程上了。
completely over my five-year relationship within a week after ending things? So I don't know whether this person has just broken up with their partner or has been broken up for a while, I think if you've just broken up with them and you're like, I feel great. It's probably just shock. I remember breaking up with my first serious boyfriend and I was like, I'm over it. I'm fine for the first three months. And then it was like, whoop, delayed reaction, set in. So I think it's just shock if you've just broken up with them. But if not, and if you're a little bit down the line, it may have been that you had already checked out. You may not have known it. You probably do know this though. You had already checked out of the relationship. You'd already tried to make it work and it wasn't working. You had
在结束五年恋情后的一周内就彻底释怀了？所以我不知道这个人是刚和伴侣分手，还是已经分手一段时间了。我觉得如果你刚和他们分手，然后觉得自己感觉很好，那可能只是处于震惊之中。我记得和我第一个认真交往的男友分手时，我想着我已经放下了，前三个月我感觉都挺好的。然后就像是“啪”的一下，延迟反应开始了。所以我觉得如果你刚分手，这只是震惊。但如果不是，而且已经过去一段时间了，那可能是因为你早就已经心不在焉了。你可能自己都不知道，不过你其实心里是有数的，你对这段感情早就已经心灰意冷了。你已经努力去维系它，但没有用，你已经
already found the closure while you were still with the person. You were already imagining what you were going to do after you'd broken up. You were already processing what it would mean to lose them. You were already imagining your life without them. You were already, yeah, essentially getting through it before you were going through it. I think that's probably the explanation. It's not a weird thing at all. People handle grief and loss and heartache so differently. But I think what is most likely happened is either you are in shock or you have already done, yeah, you basically already found closure and you've already checked out whilst you were in the relationship without even realizing it. All right. Question number five. I'm worried it will
在还和那个人在一起的时候就已经找到了释怀的感觉。你已经在想象分手后你要做什么了。你已经在消化失去他们意味着什么了。你已经在想象没有他们的生活了。你其实已经在经历这一切之前，就已经挺过来了。我觉得这可能就是解释。这一点也不奇怪。人们处理悲伤、失落和心碎的方式大不相同。但最可能发生的情况要么是你处于震惊之中，要么就是你基本上已经释怀了，在甚至没有意识到的情况下，当你在那段感情中时，你已经心生去意了。好了，第五个问题。我担心它会
always hurt this bad and I'll never find someone who loves me as well as they did. What do I do? I want you to remember that humans are really tough creatures. They adapt and they survive terrible things and you will survive this. The wound right now is so raw and it's so painful and you are at the beginning of a very long journey but you have no choice but to make this journey. At the beginning you are going to be angry. You're going to be resentful and annoyed and frustrated by the fact you have to make this journey. You're going to maybe sit and cry for a few days on the side of the mountain, but then slowly you'll get in a groove and you'll start noticing things that are nice about the journey and you'll realize it's actually really teaching you things and strengthening
就像开头总是令人沮丧且艰难，但你一定会遇到新的人。我现在向你保证这一点。也许不是立刻，也许不是在接下来的几年里，但你一定会的。你会意识到这段真正了解自己的时光是多么特别。再次记住，有些人嫁给了你刚刚分手的这类人的翻版，他们用短期的痛苦去换取了几年后才追上他们、让他们深感不满的现实，所以你为未来的自己做了一件巨大、巨大的善事。你现在已经替未来的自己承受了痛苦，而且我相信一份伟大的爱正在向你走来。爱也有着许许多多的形式。也许现在并不是你生命中追求浪漫之爱的时期，而是追求柏拉图式的爱、亲情之爱、来自宠物的爱、或是来自陌生人的爱的时期。
you and pretty soon you'll just be on the journey for you. Like the beginning is frustrating and it's hard, but you will find someone new. I promise you that right now. Maybe not right away, maybe not in the next few years, but you will. And you'll realize how special this time of knowing yourself really was. Remember, again, there are people who marry their version of the person that you just broke up with and they avoid short-term pain for a dissatisfaction that catches up with them years later so you have done your future self a huge huge favor you have endured the pain for them now and i do believe a big love is coming for you and and love also comes in so many forms maybe right now this is not the period in your life for romantic love it's the
别人生活中的浪漫之爱从外表看起来非常美好，我们常常会理想化他们所拥有的一切。但这其实很难，充满挑战，需要付出努力。所以总有一天，你会需要优先考虑这一点，你会需要为了某个人做出牺牲，你会再次拥有重获浪漫爱情的喜悦。但在那之前，这是一个美好的阶段，你可以爱自己，也可以爱他人。坦然接受它本来的样子吧。这个篇章和其他任何篇章一样重要。
period for platonic love or familial love or love from a from a pet or love from strangers Romantic love in other people's lives looks really great from the outside and often we idealize what they have. But it is hard, it is challenging and it takes work. And so there will come a time when you will have to prioritize that, when you will have to make sacrifices for someone else, when you will have the joy of being in romantic love again. But until then, this is a beautiful period where you can love yourself, you can love others. Take it for what it is. this chapter is just as important as any other chapter.
最后一个问题：当你的前任已经开始新生活时，你该怎么办？这真的超级难，我知道很难，因为我经历过我谈过的每一段感情。在三个月内，和我约会过的人都有了新对象，而我当时从来没有过新对象，而且这总是非常痛苦。现在我认为这是一个绝对的祝福。我认为这简直是上天赐予的礼物，我对此感激不尽，因为这是宇宙通过把另一个人安排到我面前来为我把这扇门彻底关上。我只想说：祝他们好运，恭喜他们找到了另一个人，也许这是一段反弹式恋情，也许不是。
Final question, what do you do when your ex has moved on? This is super tough and I know it's tough because this has happened to me in every single relationship I have been in. Within three months, the person I have dated is with someone new and I have never been with someone new when that has happened and it's been always been painful. I now consider it an absolute blessing. I consider it just, I'm so grateful for it because it is the universe closing the door for me by putting someone else in my way. And I just think that lucky them, congrats to them, they've found someone else, maybe it's a rebound, maybe it's not.
最后一个问题，当前任已经开始新生活时，你该怎么办？这真的超级难，我知道这很难，因为这发生在我经历过的每一段感情中。在三个月内，我约会过的人就和别人在一起了，而发生这种情况时，我从来没有和新的人在一起过，这总是让人痛苦。我现在认为这绝对是一种恩赐。我甚至对此非常感激，因为这就像是宇宙通过把另一个人安排在我的路上，来为我关上一扇门。我只是觉得他们真幸运，恭喜他们找到了新伴侣，也许这只是个替代品，也许不是。
It's indicative that you are taking time to heal and to do the work. And they are probably not doing that. If someone has rebounded almost immediately after, you guys have broken up, they're not. over it. They're not fine. They are not okay. This is a distraction and you could be in a relationship if you wanted. Like very easily, you could easily be in a relationship if you settled and lowered your standards enough, but you're not doing that. You're doing the hard work and that is an investment that pays off in dividends. I have an episode on this titled, Your Ex Moved on, Now What? I would really recommend that you listen to that episode. In general, I also have another
这表明你在花时间疗愈并做出努力。而他们可能并没有这么做。如果有人在你们分手后几乎立刻就有了新欢，他们并没有放下。他们并不好。他们一点也不好。这只是一种转移注意力的方式，如果你愿意的话，你也可以谈恋爱。非常轻松地，如果你愿意将就并适当降低标准，你完全可以轻易谈恋爱，但你没有这样做。你在做艰难的工作，这是一项回报丰厚的投资。我有一集关于这个的节目，标题是《你的前任放下了，接下来呢？》。我强烈建议你去听听那一集。总的来说，我还制作了另一集
episode titled How to Get Over Someone You Can't Stop Thinking About that I think is really good for these situations. But all in all, if you have just ended a long-term relationship in your 20s, I feel you, I see you, I know it is so difficult, I know that it is probably so disorientating right now, you're holding these two versions of yourself in either hand and trying to figure out who you were before, who you are now, who you want to be, but you will get there. And this is a beautiful chapter in your life. And one day you're going to be sleeping next to someone that you love and they're going to be snoring and the bed's going to be too small and your kids are going to be screaming and you'll just want one more night alone exactly how you are right now. So appreciate it. Be grateful
标题为《如何走出那个你挥之不去的人》的节目，我认为对这些情况非常管用。但总而言之，如果你在20多岁时刚刚结束了一段长期恋爱，我懂你，我看见你，我知道这太艰难了，我知道现在可能让人如此迷茫，你手里抓着自己的两个版本，试图弄清楚以前的你是谁、现在的你是谁、你想成为谁，但你一定能做到。这是你人生中美好的一章。总有一天，你会睡在某个你爱的人身旁，他们会打鼾，床会变得太小，你的孩子会大喊大叫，而你只会想要哪怕一个人的夜晚，就像你现在这样。所以，请珍惜它。要心怀感激
for it. Know that love is going to come for you. It's going to find you. And in the meantime, love yourself enough for that to be enough. Love yourself enough for that to fill the void and to fill what was perhaps left by this previous person. So I hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope that it brought you some peace, some clarity, some answers, some cool facts, if nothing else. Share it with a friend who you think maybe I would resonate or share it to Instagram story. I love seeing where everyone is listening from. Make sure that you are following along on Instagram at that psychology podcast. If you want to be able to send in your own listener questions, you guys had some fantastic questions today. They were.
并知道爱情终究会降临。它会找到你的。在此期间，多爱自己一点，让这份爱就足够了。多爱自己一点，用它去填补空白，填补前任或许留下的空缺。希望你喜欢这一集。希望它能带给你一些平静、一些清晰、一些答案、一些很酷的冷知识，除此之外别无所求。把它分享给一个你认为会有共鸣的朋友，或者分享到Instagram故事里。我喜欢看大家都在哪里收听节目。确保在Instagram上关注@that psychology podcast。如果你想发送自己的听众问题，你们今天的提问太棒了。它们真的很
were so good, so fun to answer. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. I love you. Good luck. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
真的太好了，回答起来很有趣。但下次见之前，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我爱你们。祝好。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在奇怪的现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
也就是TWO%。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并尝试弄清楚我们是如何在朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下挺过来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. how many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男性穿着一身铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不容好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marncini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。